ici chez josette c'est un petit havre de
paix pour les plantes mais surtout pour
les orchidées
une passion dévorante découvert un peu
par hasard avec une première orchidées
récupérer chez sa belle-mère
ce jardin elle le fait seule maintenant
depuis 20 ans à l'époque on pouvait se
déplacer on pouvait voyager ramener des
plantes
donc j'ai fait l'asie je fais la
thaïlande le vietnam
j'ai fait l'amérique du sud donc j'ai pu
ramener des spécimens assez rare
heureusement maintenant c'est fini
donc j'essaie de le conserver le plus
précieusement la collection de josette a
bien grandi aujourd'hui des milliers
d'orchidées peuple son jardin une
centaine de variétés des plus communes
plus rares aux origines parfois
lointaines c'est une honte si clients
niva noir et à la verte mais la noire
est assez rare d'autres sont présentes
en martinique et 6 et lépide un épi de
l'homme violait endémique de la
martinique
il y en avait tout plaît dans le nord de
la martinique pour parvenir à une telle
collection
cette passionnée de botanique dispose de
deux serres comme celle ci des salles de
soins et de rempotage pour préserver
mardi plier ses petites protégées
c'est lourd donc je profite pas ce que
je suis au traité je peux plus t'en les
mon mari est un retraité donc nous
travaillons de là dessus et simplement
du boulot c'est tous les jours pour les
jours pour les jours pour les jours
josette nicole fait partie d'une
association d'orchidophilie en
martinique ils sont une centaine de
membres à s'échanger les spécimens les
plus rares certaines de ces plantes
seront exposées ce week-end est proposée
à la vente pour le grand public
on garde bien là tu peux sortir en plus
tu as un une jeune pousse cailloux
nous mettons toujours à disposition un
stand de rempotage et le conseil donc
les mêmes qui les personnes qui
viendront pourront profiter de nos
conseils puisque nous sommes des
passionnés
et avons de quoi nous parlons leur
kidexpo permettra donc au plus grand
nombre de découvrir ces orchidées
parfois exceptionnels par leur rareté
mais il sera aussi question de
désacraliser cette plante considérée
comme difficile par les jardiniers
amateurs